une séquence qui a énormément fait
parler hier c'est quand élise lucet et
cdh interviewé nicolas sarkozy mais
l'ancien président fait lui répond pas
il part en voiture vous allez voir même
quand sarkozy est déjà dans sa voiture
en ville à 50 mètres elle veut faire
encore genre à lui pas le genre le gars
il entend dans la voiture un arcade
ouf quoi en direct le gagne pas en
skateboard durand et quoiqu'ils la mort
regardez j'ai pris conscience sarkozy
bonjour c'est élise lucet ça fait des
mois que on enquête sur le présumé
financement de votre campagne de 2007
par l'état libyen
on a recueilli une dizaine de
témoignages une dizaine de témoignages
c'est beaucoup est-ce que vous allez
reçu de l'argent libyen pour la campagne
de 2007 monsieur sarkozy est ce qu on
veut espérer une interview au calme
monsieur sarkozy monsieur sarkozy ce
serait important qu'on puisse avoir
votre avis et qu'on puisse avoir vos
explications sur le financement de votre
campagne en 2007
bon ben bonne journée monsieur sarkozy
vous montrer les vraies images pendant
un instant puisqu'on les a boudés voir
oui mais honnêtement il a raison
matthieu chalmé d'une enquête
elle l'a condamné ont comme point de
départ c'est pas du journalisme il est
passé à charge totalement à charge et à
un procès mais la production et laure
séduisant cédric et on dirait ton cpe
aller insupportable on avait vu filer
des claques france 1 en 8es payé mais ça
vous allez gérer l'effort vous allez j'y
vais pas fort elle me mois le mât
support très bref calmez-vous cobalt en
effet valérie non c'est vrai il ya des
deux chaussures sur la forme ils ont ils
ont pensé que faire moderne c'était être
décalés comme ça or je pense que c'est
une vraie erreur on pouvait faire
moderne différemment comme parfois comme
par exemple ces huit là fait sur kim
jong-un il ya d'autres façons d'être
moderne et de rester crédit parce qu'à
ça décrédibilise pas mal de sous sur le
fond pardon mais on n'a rien appris tout
ce qu'ils nous ont dit médiapart la
sortie en 2015 et en 2018 donc je vois
pas le cas il ya un boulot parce qu'ils
sont allés sur les lieux mais ils ont
récupéré des images du jt de tf1
ils ont récupéré des militaires du de
mediapart ils ont raison pardon mais
pour moi langues